We have seen previously that angle
bisectors and perpendicular bisectors
of a triangle meet at one single point do the
medians of a triangle meet at one single
point Let's draw a triangle to understand what
medians are Look at the
triangle as we have seen d on
Segment b s true that it
means d is the mid point of segment b
s the segment b s is the side opposite the
vertex a
a segment drawn from a vertex to the
mid point of its opposite side is called a median
so segment ad is one  Of the median
of triangle A S
Similarly if e is the mid point of
segment A then segment B is another median
of a triangle Now we have to see if the median from point
C
passes through this point so if A is
a mid point of  A The segment C A is the
last median of this triangle and we can see that it passes through that
point We can say that all the medians are connected they meet at
one single
point Let's say they meet at point G This
point is the median of  A triangle meet is
called one of the centroids
of a triangle The centroids
situations in real
life suppose you have a pencil on which you wish
to balance a triangular shaped
cardboard you will observe that there is
exactly one point at which this will happen there is only
one point  At Which It Will Be
Balanced And That Point Will Be The
Centroid's Triangle It
Will Always Be Balanced At The
Centered This Point Is Refer To As The Center
Of
Gravity Basically The Mass Of This Object
Is Concentrated At This One Single
Point Wt If We th  To hold the piece of
cardboard using string so that it does not
tilt in any direction
a that will happen at just one
single point we called the centered does the
centered always lie inside the
triangle this recording from math
open.com will help us understand  That to
change the shape and the size of the triangle let us
try moving the vertex a around
no matter where it is moved the
centroids
b it will remain inside and it is the same case
with text c Actually it is kind of
intuitive if we look at  Our Previous
Examples If we want to balance the
cardboard at a point which is the
centroids it
cannot lie outside it will
always lie inside the triangle There is another interesting
concept about the median which we will see in
the next
video